it's a story with suggestions of a
scandal one that could threaten a
presidency at its Center is a laptop the
computer belongs to Hunter Biden son of
Joe the U.S president it's been all the
talk particularly in Trump supporting
circles for years by the way whatever
happened to Hunter where the hell is he
no republicans in Congress want to
investigate the hunter Biden Affair so
what are the allegations against them
what could be the implications for his
father the U.S president
the story was reported in the right-wing
New York Post before the 2020 election
it went like this it was 2019 and Joe
Biden was soon to run against Donald
Trump for the presidency Hunter Biden
went into a computer repair shop he
wanted to recover data from some broken
laptop computers but he never returned
to pick them up eventually the computer
repairman John Paul mckisac looked at
what was on the laptops as he says he
was allowed to under a so-called 90-day
abandonment procedure
what did the computer repairman find
well quite a lot homemade pornography
embarrassing photos but it was the email
traffic that turned this into a more
serious matter
Hunter Biden used to be on the board of
a Ukrainian Energy company called
burisma and John Paul McIver claims the
laptop contained evidence that Hunter
Biden used this connection with his
father to help in this role something
that would amount to corruption
one email from a consultant to the firm
read Dear Hunter thank you for inviting
me to DC and giving an opportunity to
meet your father and spend some time
together the announcement of my guys
upcoming travels now now my guy hunter
refers to his father as my guy or the
chairman or the big guy Joe Biden says
he's never discussed his son's overseas
dealings with him he's dismissed the
whole story as Russian disinformation
but Isaac the computer repairman who
says he voted for Donald Trump in the
2016 election made a copy of the
laptop's contents and then told the FBI
in December 2019.
the story eventually made its way to the
New York Post
it was seized upon by Mr Trump and his
supporters but it didn't make the impact
the mites have been expected
the FBI made clear their concerns about
Russian disinformation ahead of the 2020
election subsequently Facebook and
Twitter restricted the spread of a
laptop story on their platforms
Joe Biden won the 2020 election the
laptop story wasn't given the scale of
coverage that might have been expected
but it's now back in the spotlight
Republicans control the House of
Representatives in the U.S and in the
new session of Congress they've promised
to investigate claims of corruption this
evidence raises troubling questions
about whether President Biden is a
national security risk
and about whether he is compromised by
Foreign governments Republicans in the
house are also planning to look into
illegal immigration at the Mexican
border and the U.S government's handling
of covert 19. it's all part of a wider
effort to undermine the Biden
Administration with an eye on the 2024
election
how big an impact the tale of the hunter
Biden laptop will have is yet to be seen
but it's one story that isn't going away